[Musique]
en plein pays béarnais rien
d'exceptionnel à ce que des bergers
champ que cet hymne à la gloire de la
montagne mais quand ce champ retenti
dans l'hémicycle entonnés à pleins
poumons par un élu de la république la
scène devient incongru s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît vous pouvez vous asseoir
et ne pas chanter danser des beasty
asseyez-vous moi ça fait
celui-là c'est jean lassalle
à
ermont
un
député udf inconnu du grand public
aujourd'hui à la une de la presse tout
cela pour avoir réclamé haut et fort 23
gendarmes pour sa circonscription au
tunnel du somport
l'assemblée nationale c'est un humour la
représentation du peuple s'exprime avec
la voie et la voix c'est fait pour
parler mais c'est fait aussi pour
chanter au pays on approuve la méthode
envie de rire j'étais ton appel à lévis
s'ils ne nous entendent pas au natal à
noter que plus fort on se déplace et
visiblement là c'était un petit peu le
cas ils n'étaient pas entendus il a dit
autrement mais aujourd'hui jean lassalle
et rester bouche cousue le président
avait averti et donc il n'ya pas de
chansons aujourd'hui
mais avec le sourire la parole
du moins ce n'est pas prévu le temps de
la ritournelle est passé la parole est à
monsieur olivier jardé
[Musique]